Now that we know a little bit more about what Niagara is and how we can use it to create
effects, let's go ahead and take a look at creating our first effect.
And what we're going to be doing is we're going to be creating this smoke right here.
Now we're going to focus just on the Niagara aspect of that.
And because of that, what we're going to be doing is we're going to actually be working
with some content that exists inside of the starter content.
So if you haven't done so or if you're not sure about this, what you can do is you come
up here to add and go add feature or content pack.
And then from the wizard that comes up, go over here to content and then select starter
content and press add to project.
Once you've done that in your content browser, you will now have this collection of starter
content and the piece of content that we're going to be focusing in on is this smoke material
right here.
Now, this is from the old Cascade example, which is the old way to do effects inside
of Unreal Engine.
There are two nodes that I want to call out because this material is actually really set
up great to work with smoke, especially a lit smoke.
The first thing is this particle color.
Notice that it has the RGB multiplied by the texture sample that represents its base color
and it also has the alpha done the same thing.
The reason that this is important is if we want to work with this data inside of Niagara,
we need to make sure that this particle color node is connected.
The other thing, depth fade, this node makes it so that when this particle intersects geometry,
there's a nice fade.
This can be really expensive, especially if you have a lot of particles or your particles
are very large, so just keep that in mind.
Some of the other things to note about this material is its blend mode is set to translucent.
This will allow us to get this smoke that looks kind of semi see-through and will also
react with our level lighting by changing our lighting mode to volumetric directional.
Last but not least, we increase the shadow density scale to 3.0.
This is purely an artistic choice.
Just to make things look a little bit cooler, please feel free to mess around with any of
the numbers in there to see how they'll affect the smoke in different ways.
To get started now, what we're going to do is we're going to create a new Niagara system.
Then what we're going to do is from the wizard that comes up, we're going to select the lightweight
fountain.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
Inside the editor here, I'm going to come up to my content folder, right-click, Niagara
system, and then template, fountain, create.
I'm going to call this smoke.
NS for Niagara system, smoke.
Let's go ahead and double-click on it to open it up.
Then what we're going to do is we're going to look for this m smoke sub-UV.
This material right here is the material that we are going to place on our effects.
To do that, what we're going to do is we're going to hit control space.
Then I'm going to come down here for our starter content.
If we go to particles and then materials, we can actually find it right there.
Those are m smoke sub-UV.
We can add this a number of ways.
Easiest way is we can actually just drag and drop this.
I need to click on that first.
We can drag and drop it now over here.
It will line up.
We can see it, if I was to pause here, we can see here it's not really lining up.
That is because a sub-UV is actually playing a series of images to give the illusion of
motion.
By default, it thinks that we, one by one, it thinks there's a mapping of one image to
one piece of geometry.
That's just not the case.
This is actually a 64 by 64.
That means that we have eight images in the x-axis and eight images in the y-axis.
To fix our problem here, what we do is we come over in the details panel to sub-UV.
We just change our sub-image size to 8 by 8.
If you don't know where that is, you just need to click on the sprite renderer right
down here and then our sub-UV size.
We're going to go 8 by 8.
It's going to give us these nice looking little clouds that we're going to now adjust
to give us something that looks a little bit more like smoke.
First off, we're going to adjust our spawn rate, our lifetime, and our size.
These are all going to be found in the same spot.
What we're going to do is we're going to come up here to our particle spawn.
Our lifetime right now, it's between 1.4 and 1.75.
I'm actually going to change this to direct set.
We're going to give this a lifetime of 5.
Then what we're going to do here is we're going to go to our...
Up one more, there's our spawn rate right there.
We're going to change this to 20.
Then what we're going to do is we're going to come down to our initialized particle one
more time and we're going to go to our sprite attributes here.
Instead of random uniform under sprite size mode, we're going to say uniform and change
this to 64.
This is going to give us a uniform sprite size instead of a random sprite size.
Again, we changed our spawn rate to 20.
We set our lifetime here to 5 and our uniform sprite size to 64.
What we're going to do next is we're going to change our velocity, adjust the size that
the particles are spawned from, and then disable our gravity force because it's working against
us right now.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
First off, let's go ahead and disable our gravity force because that's really going
to work against us right now.
Then what we're going to do here is under our add velocity, we're not going to do that
in a cone, we're just going to change that to linear.
That's going to give us access to our x, y, and z axis right here.
You can see here we've already got quite a difference there.
Let's change this to maybe like 80 for right now.
Give us a smoke that is kind of fast moving up.
Then what we're going to do here is we're going to go to our shape location and we're
going to increase this to say 20.
You can see here that kind of spreads the smoke out a little bit.
It gives it kind of a wider surface area.
It looks like it's spawning for something a little bit larger.
Okay.
Next, what we're going to do is we need to adjust our alpha channel because right now
when the smoke comes in, it is full alpha and it actually is kind of jarring.
Let's check this out.
What we want to do here is it's got this nice fade out, but it doesn't have this really
great fade in.
Basically what we want is something like this.
We want a fade with, we don't have any fade.
It's actually backwards, but we want a fade with a nice fade right here.
We want to change this so that it fades in and fades out.
To do that, what we're going to do is we are going to come to our scale color.
We should have this scale alpha.
If you don't, you can just come here and just look for a curve.
If you don't have one, actually this one up here, sorry, a float from curve.
That will add this little input right here.
What we're going to do is at 0.5, we're going to add this.
We're going to actually set its value to 1.
Then we're going to set the beginning values to 0 and 0.
We have this curve that goes like this.
That's going to give us something that fades in and then it fades out.
The next thing that we want to do is we are going to add our controls to animate our sub-UV.
Right now, if we look at our smoke, it's actually not really doing anything.
It's just kind of hanging out there.
It looks really cool, but it's not actually animating.
If we come down here to particle update and we look for something called sub-UV, we have
this sub-UV animation.
As soon as we click on that, what's going to happen is it's going to put it on there,
but we get this error right here.
Under our sprite renderer, we need to select sprite renderer.
Once we do that, we are going to get, and it's very subtle, but you should see the smoke
looking like it is actually playing some animation.
This just gives it a little bit more realism and a little bit more life.
We might need to maybe come down here and come to our spawn rate and maybe change this
to 15.
We can see the smoke moving around and things like that.
That's really cool.
What we're going to do next is we are going to expose some parameters.
This is a really great feature of Niagara because you can expose many different parameters
to your user.
First off, let's go to our spawn rate here.
Right next to our spawn rate, we're going to click on this.
We're going to look for user.
We have this read from new user parameter.
I'm going to click on that.
If I come over here to my user parameters, this might be set on parameters.
Make sure you click on user parameters.
You can see the spawn rate.
If I'm just going to save this and I'm going to just pull this in the level, you don't
have to do this part right now.
What we're going to do is we're going to look for this, browse to this.
If I drag this into the level, check this out.
When I come down to the Niagara system user parameters here, I'm going to save this spawn
rate so I can set this to something really crazy, 89.
What we want to do now is let's spend some time exposing some various parameters and
things like that, such as maybe like the sphere radius here.
Right-click user parameter.
We have our sphere radius.
We want our add velocity, read from new user parameter, compile and save.
We have all of this cool stuff that we can now do inside of here.
You know, we'll offset this.
It's blowing backwards now.
All types of really, really cool stuff that we could do.
Well, that was a little bit too much.
There we go.
Now, spend a little bit of time doing that.
When we come back, what we'll do is we will take a look at how we can adjust this for
level lighting.
All right.
We're going to take a pause right here and then we're going to come back and we're going
to set this up to work with level lighting.
Now that you have added a couple of controls, let's put this in a level and show you how
it can easily work with your level lighting.
So, let's just pop back over here to Unreal.
What I'm going to do for now is I'm actually going to close this and I'm going to do a
file new level.
What I'm going to do is completely empty level and hit create and we're not going to save
that.
Then what I'm going to do is hit control space, grab my smoke and just bring it in.
Then here in my transform, I'm just going to zero these values out and hit F to kind
of focus in on this.
It looks like it's lit now, but if I go into game mode, I'm not going to see anything.
So, if I hold down L and click, I'm going to add a light and I'm just going to, again,
zero it, it transforms and I'm going to change it to a red light.
Then what I'm going to do is hold down alt and bring over another one.
I'm going to change this one to green and you can see here that as soon as I do that,
I get this nice yellow and that is because it is actually mixing the two colors there.
So you can see there's my green and it becomes more red.
And that's because of our material setup being set to allow translucency and also our lighting
being set up to work with volumetric non-directional.
You can see how powerful some of those settings can be to give us something that looks like
this.
And let's see, maybe we need, I think we might need one more light back here.
I think we were just hitting like a weird light frustum thing there.
So actually set this one to blue.
So there we go, there's blue.
And then we're getting white because that's the combination of everything.
So that's really, really cool that it's kind of really true to mixing everything together.